Let's go to our caller from the 7 8 5 area
code, which I believe is is that Kansas?
7 8 5?
David, it is by a promise of camp is a straw.
OK, good.
You scared me for a second there.
No, no, David.
My name's Mark.
I'm calling from Kansas.
And real quick.
I got one thing on Cauvin and one thing on
media literacy class thing.
Do you think that suicide rates are gonna
skyrocket with the increased isolation and
the loneliness?
And then also, do you think that we're going
to see a rise in domestic violence with people
who live in abusive households that are now
going to be in those households 24/7 instead
of having work or school to go to?
You know, I worry about all of those things
I do.
And I've not been you know, I try to find
a balance between I want to if I can try to
prevent a bad situation, I want to try to
do it.
I also don't want to put attention on on things
that I may be giving more attention than than
it deserves.
But because you brought it up, I'm worried
about both of those things, to be perfectly
honest.
And I don't really have any, you know, think
the ideas being floated around at least for
the loneliness are and end the depression.
Get in touch with people via technology and
so on and so forth.
But it's like, is that enough?
Is that really a solution?
I don't know.
So, yes, I'm worried about both of those things.
All right.
And then there was a very short time ago,
you own a YouTube clip, I saw you said something
and I haven't mentioned or refind it, but
it was when you were talking about media literacy,
when you were an adjunct professor.
It was like some sort of, like, acronym.
Oh, yeah.
And it's you had about.
Right.
Primary sources.
It's called.
And you go over there real quick.
Yeah, I can write it down.
It's C. a.p.'s caps like capslock.
You know the thing that trumpets it turn on
their keyboard when they tweet.
OK.
Kaps critically analyze primary sources, critically
analyze primary sources.
That's your meat, that's your acronym for
starting to be a more responsible and savvy
news consumer.
Critically analyze primary sources.
Right.
All right.
Thanks a lot, David.
All right, my friend.
Great to hear from you.
Always.
Always love hearing from Kansas, even if there
is a risk that I'm picking up on the Kansas
troll.